audio la place saint sulpice dans le 6e
arrondissement de paris est transformée
l'espace de quelques jours en village
poétique à l'occasion du marché de la
poésie qui se termine ce dimanche créé
en 83 par l'éditeur jean michel place il
réunit près de 500 éditeurs c'est la
18ème édition reportage geneviève mollet
dean richards pense que j'avais partir
de partir ils ont entre 7 et 8 ans
l'année dernière ils savaient à peine
lire aujourd'hui ils disent baudelaire
rimbaud whitman ou apollinaire dans leur
école ils disent sans poésie supplante
ya trop de sens vraiment imaginer
c'est vraiment quelqu'un choix nous
emporte
il falloir ouvrir les portes du royaume
et plus le royaume est merveilleux donc
plus les textes sont bons puis ça marche
évidemment si on fait naître ça tout
d'un coup on y plonge avec vous et qui
vous leur ferez une forte et puis une
seconde et puis après ils seront tous
c'est lourd alors trois points forts
dans ce marché de la poésie des enfants
de ce corps élémentaire ou fait un tabac
même auprès de ceux très sérieux qui
sont venus se ressourcer dans tous ces
textes qui anna et feuilles le monde car
la poésie ici prend tout son sens dira
l'autre côté des choses
l'indicible dans le brouhaha toujours
plus bruyants qui nous cernent le poète
arrive a révélé le monde
quand il arrive à trouver sa propre
identité et à la transmettre
effectivement je pense que là il rejoint
il rejoint peut-être quelque chose
d'universel
le poème c'est cet endroit où souvent
mise en pension ou mises au rebut
les objets les êtres les réalistes et
dialogues les mauvaises raisons
avec des mots pour le dire les mots
cachés dans la matière comme dans ses
sculptures livres de l'atelier des g des
mots au vent de l'esprit place à une
cuisse à paris